hey Oliver how are you I'm great day
thanks for taking my car sure what's up
alright so before I read your book I
actually filed bankruptcy and I have
about around eighty thousand it dead
including about 48,000 event in student
loans
that's all that's not survived at the
bankruptcy right now I don't start
didn't get your question I'm sorry the
debt that survived the bankruptcy was
80,000 no it's around 24,000 that I'm
paying on in the bankruptcy oh okay you
say you had you're doing a chapter 13
bankruptcy that has 24,000 and outside
of the bankruptcies 80,000 no combined
with that I just combined your own oh I
got a tee time all right okay all right
so I so my full-time job I make about
$38,000 a year I'm doing uber and lyft
I'm making about 1,800 bucks a month
that's good so I completed baby step one
and I'm going into baby steps through
this month and I have a quick question
about I want to continue to do over and
lift because I would really want to get
rid of this the rest of what's outside
of the bankruptcy and I'm thinking about
being prepared you know just in case my
car breaks down because I'm sure a bill
I had 125 thousand miles on it would you
start a car fund along with paying off
the debt and baby steps you know no I'm
gonna drive that thing and you need to
get this mess cleaned up what'd you say
your income was not counting the per
lift income I 13 get out okay and then
you're making another eighteen thousand
or so on that so 1500 a month or so you
said right okay in you know so 56,000
now you're gonna you're gonna peddle
your way through it it's just gonna take
a while and obviously the bankruptcy is
gonna be the last thing you get to a
chapter 13 takes five years to go
through if you just go straight on the
plan you don't want to wait that long
you should be able to clean up the rest
of this stuff and then turn around
and get with your chapter 13 trustee and
work out an early by early payout on the
bankruptcy and get on out of there so
that you can get your life back I'm
gonna try to make that car last through
every bit of that and if you got to fix
it a couple times and it breaks down so
what fix it and drive it it's cheaper
than buying another car
and so now I'm not buying a car while
I'm getting out of debt unless it just
completely blows up and it's you know
five thousand bucks to fix it or
something and you're gonna be forced to
buy a different car but that's probably
not the case hundred twenty-five
thousand miles on a modern-day car is
not that much you can run them usually
two hundred and twenty-five 325 to take
care of them so I'd be real careful to
take good care of it so it'll last
because you're gonna need it
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or twenty seven
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income a $500,000 in
economy
you